journal la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine thème d'un nouveau
déplacement du ministre de l'intérieur
nicolas sarkozy visite précisément à
sangatte où sont regroupés vous le savez
quelques 1500 demandeurs d'asile kurde
et afghans pour la plupart qui
souhaitent gagner la grande-bretagne où
le régime est plus favorable
sangatte où des incidents sont signalés
chaque jour londres 1 réclament la
fermeture du centre
cela fait partie de nos objectifs a
indiqué nicolas sarkozy sur place
michèle fines stéphanie clark
cette fois le ministre est venu du ciel
une visite impromptue annoncé presque au
dernier moment
après strasbourg hier nicolas sarkozy a
choisi sangatte et l'insoluble problème
de ces réfugiés
il y va de notre douloureux problème on
le sait que je voulais venir
je serais ce que pouvoir comprendre les
lieux puis pas vous donner ce sentiment
est un peul aux autres que vous étiez
randonnée la presse nationale et
internationale et là c'est le plus
important
la visite sera menée au pas de charge le
comprend qui est celui de pourquoi son
édition
un peu plus loin le centre de la croix
rouge nicolas sarkozy il reste 5 minutes
sous l'oeil indifférent des clandestins
sous l'oeil agacé de la population qui
veut la fermeture de sangatte avant les
législatives
mais avant bon après parce que payer les
pros machine à dix cas suspects où les
30 secondes
alors moi tu prends d'accord les
habitants seront déçus le ministre est
venu mais n'a rien annoncé la fermeture
du centre de sangatte peut-être doit
être un objectif mais ne peut pas être
un préalable
dans quinze jours ce seront les
élections législatives ça laisse
finalement peu de temps pour engager des
réformes defour nicolas sarkozy le 7
il s'est aussi que la bataille des
élections législatives sera une guerre
de l'image
on attend